I was thinking today you've done so much
work on camera that that people know but
they may not associate you with it for
example I thought you were great you
played an evil DJ in Zoolander I played
a small part as evil DJ in Zoolander
yeah yeah and it was very fun I think we
have a still from that I really like
it's funny the minute you see you like I
remember that guy but yeah you had some
breakdancing move yeah with a big
breakdancing fight at the end of zoo
Lander it's kind of there or act 3
action sequence and and yeah so I broke
fight with Owen Wilson did you
let's you know think I'm thinking like
you're pretty good are you that's an
actual skill that I employed and as you
know the bottom of the Rays of many
stuff where I went yes and breakdance no
and a bend saw it once I was actually
Ben's wedding and I broke danced at his
wedding and you were break dancing at
Ben Stiller's wedding how'd it did you
as a young guy were you breakdancing
yeah I learned when I was around I don't
know twelve or thirteen somewhere in
there how to breakdance and and and I
had a little crew that we used to roll
around watch that and be free like a
crew I got my boys with me boys
we didn't want to fight so we wanted to
just dance things up you don't I always
wanted in a breakdance fight how do you
decide who wins just whoever does this
at the last I got a fade away on that
one
is that how I know you're you're engaged
to the beautiful Jennifer Aniston lovely
are you are
[Applause]
is that how you won her over was there a
moment where she wasn't sure you were
the guy and then you started spinning on
a cardboard box herebut for women so he
presented the ring very nice you played
another memorable character really I
thought a very memorable bad guy in
Charlie's Angels full throttle wear and
the second one yeah let's take a look
because I remember you from know you
can't hurt me anymore Holland I'm gonna
teach you and your friends about p.m.
I'm gonna kill them just so you can hear
them scream
[Applause]
it's scary he's scaring apparently he
can walk through flames he's a no-show a
walkthrough got burned off yeah exactly
is that an eye that's an Irish gyrus
it's an Irish accent which I which I
wouldn't say mastered but I did an Irish
axe you didn't I thought it was fine
whenever I've noticed that the Irish
though are very particular about someone
affecting an Irish actors they're very
territorial yes and I went later to do
another movie called your highness in
Ireland and you get into cabs to be like
you're the guy did the [ __ ] Irish accent
and the truth about the real Irish
accent is you can't understand a word I
don't know you're doing it right people
think like cows approach at the end of
every move but if you talk to a real
Irish guy oh my
I can't help but notice Justin I think
in 21 years of my doing a show you were
the first one to come out here chewing
gum you hurt you have gum in your mouth
I've seen it okay I'm not offended I
just like of first it's a new what's
with the gum it's it's I'm chewing
actually Nicorette which is a nicotine
substitute therapy yeah people who are
trying to quit smoking or have food
that's a nice plug for Nicorette you
just give yes I mean I love Nicorette
more than anyone on the planet probably
I by the way have been quitting for
seven years
I don't have to know what's out so it
tastes like does it taste like I bagged
one called cinnamon surge it doesn't
taste like cinnamon surge big red
you